a legal battle is underway between the
estate of comedian George Carlin and the
dudy podcast after the show released a
brand new AI generated George Carlin
special from my side of things it feels
like me I consider myself to be George
Carlin and from your side of things if
you've seen some of my specials from
when I was traditionally alive maybe you
might notice a small difference in the
delivery of a joke or the turn of a
phrase here or there but you have to
admit this is pretty close to the George
Carlin you remember and that's going to
have to be good enough so you might as
well enjoy it George Carlin's
daughter is leading the way on the push
back against AI generated content of her
father saying no machine will ever
replicate his genius and humans are so
afraid of the void that we can't let
what has fallen into it stay there